[Musique]
la suppression de l'ancien pont de la
ravine et wrynn à la rivière saint-louis
pour un nouvel ouvrage plus adapté aux
flux de la circulation fait partie du
programme global de suppression des
radiers présents sur les routes
départementales 156 radier seront
concernés par ce projet nous avons
défini des priorités qui tiennent compte
de trois paramètres
le premier c'est l'enclavement de la
population le deuxième paramètre la
dangerosité lié à l'occurrence dessus de
subversion le troisième paramètre trafic
du pont de la rd 400 au tampon à celui
ci dix ouvrages seront livrés d'ici la
fin de l'année pour supprimer les
radiers la structure andalo et
principalement déployées dans les
ravines ce que vous pouvez voir
effectivement derrière c'est ce qu'on
appelle communément un dalot c'est à
dire une section géométrique de forme
rectangulaire avec une base des moteurs
plus ou moins importante qui est
calculée suivant les capacités
hydrauliques recherché par rapport aux
débits attendu de l'écoulement d'eau
dans la ravine le plus grand chantier à
réaliser sera certainement la
suppression du radier de la rivière du
ouaki un ouvrage de 500 mètres de portée
qui supportera le flux de la circulation
de 7000 véhicules par jour objectif
effectivement c'est bien de réaliser un
pont donc toutefois complètement hors
d'eau quelle que soit la halle à
l'intensité pluviométrique
un ouvrage après ça peut être un ouvrage
de type courant au ban et sans appui
avec appuis j'ai à toutes les
suggestions techniques seront souvent
élevés un programme ambitieux qui
sécurise la mobilité des usagers sur les
712 km de routes départementales qui
sillonne le département
[Musique]